the new year is here and that means the
first batch of free PlayStation Plus
games for 2020 is coming soon if you're
a PS Plus subscriber and want to know
what you can grab for free here's what's
coming in January ps4 is first free game
is actually three games in one uncharted
the Nathan Drake collection includes the
first three games in the series drake's
Fortune among thieves and drake's
Deception the collection includes new
difficulty options speedrunning features
a photo mode and new trophies just for
ps4 that's a score but if you'd rather
just goof around ps4 s other game goat
simulator might just be the thing as the
name of the game says you play as a goat
and that goat can run around the sandbox
world smacking into objects and licking
random things setting off all sorts of
explosions and physics-based chaos you
know just like real goats do and those
are your free PS plus games for January
they'll be available from January 7th
through February 3rd remember that you
can always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on GameSpot and
stay tuned as we report on the new PS
Plus lineup every month
[Music]